estamos viendo Es que los países
llamados emergentes en este caso
Sudáfrica por países africanos que los
que es China y Rusia tienen una alianza
muy fuerte y cada vez más una
penetración por parte de China y Rusia
en los intereses comerciales de estos
países pues parece ser que están
desplazando lo que era antes las
potencias europeas en lo que era el
negociación y mucho más en este caso que
afecta a un país europeo aunque no de la
otan ni de la Unión Europea como es
Ucrania yo creo que este momento estamos
viendo como Rusia de una manera
indirecta se le está diciendo que debe
negociar para acabar con una guerra que
es muy complicado que tenga un control
sobre más de mil kilómetros de frontera
y por otro lado evidentemente hacen es
que se ha dejado Claro que no se puede
continuar esta línea de conflicto armado
que solo tiene dos soluciones o La Paz o
la guerra total lo cual puede implicar
la guerra nuclear por tanto ambas partes
deben llegar por bien directa a un
acuerdo sea cual sea y de la forma que
sea hablaba usted Fernando desierto
desplazamiento no de las potencias
europeas y China y Brasil también se
posicionaron como posibles
intermediarios Qué posibilidades tienen
estos países para avanzar en esta línea
pues Son los únicos países que pueden
avanzar en esta línea porque tres de
estos países evidentemente no están
Ellos están las potencias
internacionales detrás de los países
africanos o los países asiáticos en este
caso china está detrás de la India
detrás de Sudáfrica y hoy de Brasil Está
también Rusia Hay un montón de países
detrás de los cuales están las potencias
hegemónicas hasta ahora que eran Estados
Unidos
en Rusia y ahora evidentemente la
incipiente china Son los únicos que en
estos momentos dado que están fuera del
marco geopolítico de peso geopolítico y
el conflicto geopolítico que se está
marcando concretamente en Ucrania Son
los únicos que por su boca pueden pueden
hablar otros sin que se les acuse de ser
débiles o se les acuse de haber perdido
capacidad de Liderazgo por tanto quien
habla cuando habla de la India o cuando
habla Sudáfrica cuando habla Brasil se
hablan otras potencias pero así no
darían la cara ni Estados Unidos
ahora estos posicionamientos no que
realizan países y también líderes no
como posibles mediadores en el conflicto
cree usted que tienen un componente
simbólico para lo que es el
posicionamiento en la escena
internacional en la geopolítica
no eso no es un concepto simbólico
estamos volviendo a un nuevo nuevo orden
mundial en el que la potencia hegemónica
que era hasta ahora los últimos 25 años
Estados Unidos ya no lo va a ser y no lo
va a ser dentro de muy poco tiempo y por
tanto tiene que negociar de alguna
manera ese nuevo marco geopolítico en el
que los brics África Brasil Rusia Irán y
con el apoyo digamos le indirecto y
directo de China van a gobernar el resto
del mundo y Estados Unidos tendría que
aceptarlo por tanto no es un mero
símbolo sino es un digamos el incipiente
imagen de lo que va a ser la prospectiva
geopolítica en los próximos años porque
la otra solución nos lleva a un
conflicto armado directo el que nadie
saldría ganando y todo saldrían muy
perjudicados principalmente la vieja
Europa sería la más perjudicada Fernando
cocho Muchísimas gracias por este
análisis en 24